so you thought that unique mix of like
card and then strategy yes movement if
our style looks fantastic
the designs look fantastic and also I'm
doing like a little Diablo feel to going
on the lower arrival action
Thanks
so have you been given this feel at all
about the game okay okay so it's a mix
of a car game like hearthstone where you
can build a deck create how you want to
fight
beginning of a batch and then battles
play out in real time like Starcraft and
then it their patience a little bit more
like a MOBA so you play as the Harbinger
this powerful guide you can summon all
these different things so we have units
we have structures we have traps and we
have become texts their spells and so
the combination of those things you can
come up with a bunch of different ways
of playing the game so it's been amazing
you're watching different people play
keep depending on their background its
place so different it's great
kind of creating game absolutely
absolute and that's we have a little
over 100 glyphs which our cards and you
know the beginning of a match we go into
what we call the archive that's
basically you make what you want your
deck to me so you have to have at least
30 glyphs in your in your deck so we
have some mentor set requirements for
the game yeah it's at least 30 but that
just stuff out yeah you know you can you
get as many as you want so there's no
limit to how many but you know the
downside of it having a ton of cards
you're not sure which one you're going
to get there's a less of a chance and
then also you know like if you get into
we have heroes in our game they cost a
lot but if you get them at the beginning
of the game you can't really play them
too late game so you want to kind of be
careful with attack that's not too big
but then you get punished for for
reshuffling you got 15 seconds of your
stasis yeah
sure
you begin with
a challenge
it's one
unique someone says hash
that statement Oh microtransactions you
saying though my though that is yeah
I notice that that for civilian
just ran out
he's got he's got to play
he's got the
copies they're slowly dying but every
time and kill
ha
either on that
not right there
[Applause]
yeah yeah we are very interested in down
the road yes
could it be of what you have a
unavailable time later on today to play
the game I mean you all sit down now
yeah I can play well let's go right now
what actually building
I'll start off your tutorial so have you
been kind of talk to the mix of the car
game yeah I'm cool all right cool you
guys are here
and then we'll you can try for the
challenge
because of this because
good I like
for me
yes it's a horrible background yeah sup
with you I hope I'm a huge mob you guys
okay you must tell us about your
involvement with wall voltage or just in
general
yes about past 10 years ago or thin-film
doing concept art for almost all the
Transformers films except for the first
one 12-ounce ontology one guy okay yeah
hey man I always tried to push to
achieve what I promise I promise long I
did Megatron times always push back my
key was that we forgive him though
who did that but yeah so I worked on
number of Marvel films those guys are so
good I mean they're so good so I mean
infinity war coming up Black Panther
okay
[Laughter]
full record rock I did not do we're in
some of that so I thought that movie was
awesome
I'll work on the second floor a little
very cool spider-man homecoming I did
Bulger yeah
so we've been working on the game Delvin
and I saw actually
they forgot again
there's
I'm a father brother
came to us with
the program
come on Atticus child
faster energy
really the building
so hard
yeah okay
with our streamlines
yes
hold on
oh there
attack
got a Corvette filter section
margin of Moscow oneness
how is our owner on the always on the
line you guys have anything played
because you had a difficult game
conference that was just these type of
channels
yo
whatever every Louis long Lord in the
room
especially you can't move
definitely
what they are mainstream
so you want to spawn to select him and
then you want to select a carpenter here
then you want spawn into projection put
it down that with arrow is
yes sir
there you go and you're going to send
your projection up to find the other
harbingers so here
so he's kind of like your Scout you can
always make one of those he's actually
pretty powerful but he doesn't have a
lot of health but he's great so he found
the harbinger here
plus the enemy so now you can just take
your whole army up there and destroy
that guys
[Laughter]
the animatic
so you got you got vision here you can
spawn a bunch of these things right
where he is that's a big difference with
our game is you don't you don't have to
spawn like back from your face you can
spawn anything wherever you have vision
so qm which shows the people that
surround ya so Q selects everybody on
the screen
[Music]
now how do I do everyone on the whole
bath what's that
is there a way to do everyone some old
man
you can send all those guys up here just
one
Oh now so there's some friendly fire on
those fireballs
so you just destroyed some of your
buddies there that's fine now so that is
it pacified so you want to put that on
enemies that are extremely powerful so
now these guys your partner just have
tech shield so you can't pacify them you
can't certain things you can't do to
them you just have to just destroy wear
them down fighting
nice so now this guy you might want to
click on one of these feelers and then
right click on the destroyer and then
he'll be basically his buddy and it'll
just keep giving him energy he almost
got the Harbinger here
yes we have up to four player
multiplayer to piano we have
we gotta pick up the Norden around y'all
it's awesome everything that's super
cool
thank you guys thank you super golden
pigs out now now now it will be our time
when that console Easter comes we gonna
bring one of our many more fantastic all
right guys